willkommen zur aktuellen vorlesung in
der es noch einmal um die ontologie der
digitalität geht den zweiten teil dieser
abteilung nachdem in der letzten sitzung
uns auch schon etwas mit der ontologie
der digitalität befasst hatten und zwar
am beispiel der virtuellen realität die
in meinen augen der schlüsselbegriff zum
und logischen nicht mythologischen zum
gesamten verständnis der digitalität ist
ein kurzer überblick über die heutige
sitzung möchte ich zu beginn geben wir
werden zunächst ein rückblick geben auf
die sitzung und nochmal genauer
diskutieren was unter virtueller
realität eigentlich zu verstehen ist das
ist ein begriff der ist ziemlich unklar
obwohl immer mehr verwendung findet ich
mag dazu oben rechts seinen youtube den
link zu dieser sitzung ein dann kommen
wir zum eigentlichen thema der heutigen
vorlesung nämlich zu raum und zeit logik
der digitalität was auch eine
ökologische frage ist man könnte das
auch mit einem fremdwort die krone topi
der digitalität nennen also kronos die
zeit topos der ort als in welchem raum
zeitlichen verhältnis ist die
digitalität zu denken und dann gibt es
am schluss noch einen ausblick auf die
nächste sitzung ja jetzt noch mal kurz
zurück zum thema der letzten sitzung was
ist virtuelle realität ich habe da eine
ganz lagen auffassung gibt verschiedene
auffassungen ich glaube aber dass man
sie in einem sehr und rollo gestalten
sinne verstehen sollte und wenn wir
jetzt auf die begriffsgeschichte des
wortes und des begriffes
virtualität
zurückblicken dann finden wir zwei
unterschiedliche traditionen der
bedeutung einmal gibt es eine neue zahl
begriffs verwendung die immer noch sehr
präsent ist sehr dominant ist heutzutage
die eben sagt dass virtualität als
optische illusion zu verstehen ist also
hier wird virtualität stark mit
illusionen verbindung gesetzt auch mit
simulationen hier muss man nur an die
virtual reality brillen denken an das
verständnis von einer scheinwelt ziehen
an sich an diese verschiedenen
assoziationen die das letzte mal
präsentiert habe also das ist immer noch
dominant das ist eine neuzeitliche
beatles verwendung von virtualität die
aus dem optischen bereich kommt also dem
mit linsen und zwar wirklich auch sehr
konkret vorzustellen und er gibt es eine
ältere tradition von virtualität die
antik mittelalterlich ist die vom
lateinischen virtualität oder du talita
daneben als adverb die virtualität als
kraft hier steckt natürlich der das
lateinische wort virtuos drin wird es
heißt verschiedenes kann auch würde
heißen
kommt von lateinisch wäre der mann
heißt kraft jetzt alle diese kraft
aspekt der darin steckt dennoch schwingt
hier immer so ein bisschen ob die
möglichkeit mit also irgendwie
möglichkeit und kraft sind im begriff
der virtualität ganzen verwoben wenn wir
von der antiken und mittelalterlichen
tradition aus gehört natürlich auch ein
aristoteles zu denken dann an die shoah
stick aber auch bis in die neuzeit
hinein hat dieser begriff und
biologisches signifikanz zum beispiel
bei leibnitz hier kann man noch fehler
forschen hier ist noch ziemlich viel
unklar was diesen begriff anbelangt
jetzt ist es so mit dem aufkommen der
neuen medien vor allem den internet
gewinnt derzeit es sind also dieser hier
virtualität als kraft- und ja auch
insofern als realität weil überall da wo
kräfte wirken haben wir es mit realität
zu tun immer mehr an bedeutung
virtuelle realität wird nicht mehr als
eine bloße illusion verstand sondern
tritt immer mehr als eine realität
eigenen rechts in den vordergrund die
von der bloßen simulation der optischen
täuschung
und verschieden ist wie es eben die
neuzeitliche begriff verbindung
suggeriert er ist als eine trendumkehr
festzustellen in meinen augen die wieder
geht auf die ursprüngliche bedeutung
jetzt hat mir letzten sitzung nicht nur
diskutiert was virtualität ist oder was
virtuelle realität ist sein auf was der
prozess der virtualisierung bedeutet das
finde ich sogar noch viel wichtiger als
zu bestimmen was virtuelle realität ist
den begriff der virtualisierung zu
klären und ich würde ihnen bestimmen als
alternative realisierung also als eine
möglichkeit die wirklichkeit wird die
durchaus auch was mit funktionalität zu
tun hat also virtuelle realität bedeutet
eine graduelle alternative realisierungs
reise
bereits oder von bereits bestehenden
phänomen das heißt wir werden hier sehr
erfinderisch sie kreativ gebe jetzt mal
ein beispiel wir können mit ihnen mit
naturalien ich habe ein apfel den apfel
kann ich eintauschen gegen eine banane
die banane kann ich auf dieser natur
ahlen basis eintauschen vielleicht gegen
ein werkzeug dann geht es schon auf eine
höhere ebene
und so weiter und so fort wir sehen
dieses tauschgeschäft was schon ganz
lange existiert das beinhaltet eine form
von virtualität weil wir uns immer mehr
unabhängig machen können von den
ursprünglich gegebenen naturalien
beispiel wir können naturalien
virtualisieren also den wert von
naturalien die muss ich genau das sagen
virtualisieren zum wert von münzgeld das
wiederum virtualisieren oder auch
eintauschen das deutet oft empfunden und
dasselbe
diesen wert eintauschen in eine banknote
also die immer noch denselben wert hat
wie dann diese naturalien sagen wir mal
des apfels und diese banknote die immer
noch material gebunden ist auf eine
gewisse weise
umsetzen oder transformieren wäre auch
noch eine möglichkeit diesen prozess zu
bezeichnen in eine online währung die
online währung ist dann nicht nur auf
einen richtigen träger angewiesen wie
jetzt ein papier natürlich kann die
online währung und deswegen zustande
kommen oder aufrechterhalten werden
dadurch dass wir eine technische basis
haben die ihr zugrunde liegt also wir
haben server wir haben internet wir
haben strom wir haben alle möglichen
dinge die diese online wären überhaupt
ermöglichen die frage ist jetzt aber nur
können wir diese wert der online währung
diesen diese virtuelle realität
reduzieren alleine auf die technische
ausrüstung die das ermöglicht oder ist
diese unter logische bedeutung der
online wer mich doch davon zu
unterscheiden
also hier sehen wir einen schönen weg
der transformation des tausches der
virtualisierung von völlig nackt
eingebundenen werte hin zu völlig
unabhängigen werden werden von der natur
der apfel kann irgendwann fällig werden
das passiert mit der online währung
nicht des windes geld da fängt schon an
das münzgeld kann man verloren gehen das
münzgeld kann mehr schaden nehmen die
banknote viel eher dass vielfalt der
wird zerrissen der scheint kommt
irgendwo rein wird eingeklemmt und wird
in viele stücke zerrissen das ist alles
mit online währung auf diese weise nicht
mehr der fall ich will damit nicht sagen
dass nicht das auch online währung
irgendwie gefährlich sein können dass
hier die gefahr eines verlustes besteht
aber diese form des verlustes nicht mehr
von dieser art wie es die form ist ja
ein mann heiko bittet die den ton raus
machen sie man irgendwo der ton aber ich
muss sie mal alle kurz ausschalten
sollen
genau wir sehen also die
virtuellen realitäten sind unabhängig
unabhängig von den natürlichen
realitäten wie es äpfel bananen usw sind
wir machen uns unabhängig und jetzt die
frage auf welche weise wie uns davon
unabhängig machen wir machen uns kurz
gesagt unabhängig davon durch eine
andere räumliche existenzform eine
andere zeitliche existenzform dieser
virtuellen realitäten äpfel birnen
existieren raume zeit und sie nehmen
dadurch auch schon durch form zeit indem
bestimmte prozesse gärungsprozesse
freundes prozess in gang gesetzt werden
davon machen wir uns unabhängig der wert
dieses apfels nimmt ab zunehmend weil er
der raum und zeit im raum liegen und dem
zeitlichen vergehen ausgesetzt ist und
wir entheben gewissermaßen diesen wert
aus dem raum zeitlichen kontext wir
machen diesen wird unabhängig davon
indem wir ihnen virtualisieren
sie sehen die kommt schon raume zeit ins
spiel ich habe noch ein beispiel das
physische universität seminar der
universität ca im hinblick auf das
virtuelle digitale seminar das physische
universität seminar ist auch sehr
abhängig von bestimmten dingen
räumlichen dingen das virtuelle seminar
davon nicht mehr so sehr obwohl es
sicherlich auch von bestimmten dingen
abhängig ist wie zum beispiel einen
computer in diesem moment und der
internetverbindung und so weiter das
möchte ich gar nicht bestreiten
physische bücherei wird für die bücherei
universal lexikon wikipedia hat man
fragezeichen werden die letzten sitzung
sehr viel danach diskutieren über den
status von wikipedia hier soll es nicht
dass hier jetzt um die technische
bedeutung von wikipedia gehen sind
einfach um die tatsache dass es sich
dabei um eine virtualisierte leistung
handelt die von dem universal access
kann unabhängig würde und dadurch neue
formen der realität auch ins spiel
bringt es also nicht so zu denken dass
wir hier bestehendes nur anna logisch
abbilden oder modellieren im virtuellen
raum nein die virtuelle realität gewinnt
neue eigenschaften zu über die die
physische realität zuvor nicht besaß und
diese neuen eigenschaften die virtuelle
realitäten erhalten hängen wesentlich
darf ab und darum geht es in der
heutigen sitzung dass sie nicht mehr auf
eine solche weise räumlich und zeitlich
zu denken sind wie es die physischen
vorbilder sind
das heißt wir haben ja eine viel höhere
form von flexibilität spielen ebenso
fernsehen und youtube wie könnte man die
liste unendlich weiterführen das ist ein
ganz neuer trend getrennt der
virtualisierung der vereinen
lebensbereich unseres alltags halt macht
der wirklich den begriff der disruption
verdient also hier finden wirklich
radikale transformation stadt die uns
alle betreffen die dadurch natürlich
auch einige diese gefahr darstellen wenn
wir diese transformation nicht mitmachen
könne oder mitmachen wollen
jetzt komme ich auf die neuen medien
noch kurz zu sprechen die ich als eine
besondere form von virtuelle realität
interpretiere die neuen medien wie eben
zum beispiel das internet verlieren
immer mehr ihre technologische bedeutung
und langen lebens wirklich realität das
internet ist nicht mehr nur eine quelle
versucht wie es manfred spitzer wohl
sagen würde sondern es ist eine alltag
struktur bei die ich zum beispiel
aufarbeiten kann die neue medien heben
die kommunikations theoretische
unterscheidung versender und empfänger
immer mehr auf also die neuen medien wie
jetzt das internet verdienen eigentlich
gar nicht mehr so meine these medium
genannt zu werden weil das internet
vermittelt nicht primär wie es zum
beispiel ein telefonbuch oder ein
anderes medium eine zeitung oder so die
zwischen einem sender und einem
empfänger irgendeine information
getauscht sondern das internet selbst
ist gewissermaßen eine neue ebene die
sender und empfänger auf derselben ebene
miteinander in beziehung setzt und eben
diese unterscheidung dadurch auf hebt
das internet ist nicht nur ein medium es
ist ein virtueller handlungsraum auf dem
natürlich wieder neuen medien entstehen
können das sei unbestrittenes geht
internet zeitschrift und ganz klar die
dann wieder diesem sender boten modell
entsprechen aber das internet selbst
scheint mir nicht mehr im rahmen eines
mediums medienbetriebs adäquat
erfassen zu sein das heißt die neuen
medien verändern nicht nur unsere weise
der wahl gewählt was sich sicherlich tun
sind sie schaffen auch neue realität
nämlich virtuelle realität das internet
wird schon sagt ist nicht nur ein medium
ist es auch im medium aber ich glaube
nicht vor allem soll jetzt ein
virtueller handlungsraum im internet
können wir interagieren das internet ist
wie so eine gewisse rahmenbedingungen
wie eine
plattform die uns verschiedenes erst
ermöglicht und durch diese ermöglichung
wird das internet zu viel mehr als nur
einem medium was vermittelt
das heißt jetzt zugespitzt virtualität
und realität sind nicht als gegenbegriff
zu verstehen wie es häufig getan wird
sondern virtualität bestimmt nur
realität näher im sinne eines prädikats
damit meine ich virtualität und realität
sie nicht auf diese ebene angesiedelt
sondern virtualität ist eine eigenschaft
eine form von realität realität kann
verschiedene andere formen oder
eigenschaften haben oder sagen wir
genauer ausprägungen haben also
virtualität ist eine ausprägung von
realität eine erscheinungsform aber es
ist nichts was im gegensatz zur realität
auf derselben ebene gewissermaßen
angesiedelt wird soll wie ein subjekt
ein prädikat haben kann wie wir etwas
eine eigenschaft einem team zu sprechen
kann genauso verhält sich in meinen
augen virtualität zur realität
virtualität bedeutet also keine realität
dass es wieder die erste griffs
tradition die neuere die höhere oder
sogar eine gegen realität das wäre die
illusion sondern vielmehr eine form von
realität im sinne dieses prädikat sind
dieser näheren bestimmung hier habe ich
noch mal diese übersicht als es gibt
verschiedene formen von mobilität es
gibt die physikalische physische die
mentale und eben auch die virtuelle
realität zum beispiel eben geld an ge
notenwerte die dadurch garantiert sind
die eben verschieden sind von naturalien
wie die sind hier zu verorten es gibt
natürlich noch mentale realitäten
gedanken meinungen qualia also
subjektive zustände wie emotionen
stimmungen die scheinbar weder
physikalisch einzufangen zu sein noch
virtuell einzufangen design scheinbar
war sehr eng am virtuellen zu liegen
müssen aber auch genau bestimmt und dann
gibt es im bereich die realität der
fiktion simulation fusion fast also wie
gesagt nicht bedeuten soll dass es hier
nicht noch weitere unterpunkte geben
könnt das möchte ich hiermit nichts
sagen das nur als versuch eine klärung
dieser beiden begriffe die häufig nicht
ganz
eindeutig in ein verhältnis gesetzt
werden und so quelle von verschiedenen
konfessionen werden das möchte ich noch
kurz auf die modalität der virtuelle
realität eingehen wir müssen den begriff
der virtuellen realität mit blick auf
die begriff der möglichkeit wirklichkeit
fiktion simulation und illusion klären
um aussagen eine anthologie und auch
eine ethik der digitalität treffen zu
können wenn wir virtualität nur
virtuelle realität nur als eine
simulation oder eine illusion verstehen
dann hat das natürlich auch auswirkungen
auf die ethische bewertung dieser
virtuellen realität wenn sie nur als
simulation zu verstehen ist wie sie
nicht zu bedeutsam normativ sie ist nur
eine spielerei wie sie es wäre wenn sie
wirklich eine realität wäre dann müssten
wir darüber optisch ganz anders sprechen
das heißt es hängt sehr viel davon ab
wie wir virtuelle realität verstehen um
eine ethik der digitalität entwickeln zu
können wie wir sie in der nächsten
sitzung einmal in angriff nehmen werde
das heißt das wäre meine these
digitalität dieses ganze phänomen ist
das paradigma der virtuellen realität es
gibt auch virtuelle realität außerhalb
des digital habe ich gezeigt zum
beispiel mit banken oder der wert einer
banknote ist virtuell obwohl der
digitalisierung keine rolle spielten sie
in der technik
dennoch glaube ich dass digitalität
aufgrund seiner zeit logik auf die ich
gleich näher eingehen das paradigma der
virtuellen realität ist also der
paradefall die beispielhafte form
virtuelle realität weil sie sich maximal
emanzipiert von physische realität die
eben zum beispiel im falle der banknote
noch durch die unterliegende papier
struktur vorhanden ist
das heißt virtuelle realitäten sind raum
zeitlich unabhängig von ihren physischen
vorbildern also ich gebe ein beispiel
noch mal wir haben die naturalien den
apfel und der hat einen wert und wir
haben ein online guthaben was dem
entspricht das online guthaben ist viel
unabhängiger von der physischen natur
als es der wert der natur ali ist
dennoch existieren virtuelle realität
nicht unabhängig von physischen realität
luftleeren raum das ist nämlich so eine
gefahr die damit verbunden ist virtuelle
realitäten konstituieren keine gegenwelt
da ist jetzt nicht plötzlich wird eine
neue welt herum zu sind ja über welt
aber so
parallelwelt so dürfen wir uns die
virtuelle realität nicht vorstellen das
heißt wir müssen die virtuelle realität
jemand ein bestimmtes verhältnis zur
physischen realität bringen
virtuelle realitäten hängen so fern von
der physischen realität ab als sie auf
ihr agieren jetzt habe ich hier wieder
einen schwierigen begriff gepackt
reagieren was heißt reagieren erst mal
ganz allgemein gesagt sie werden dadurch
ermöglicht und treten auf dieser basis
auf als wir brauchen immer etwas
physisches damit mir virtuelle realität
erzeugen können geben beispiel ein mit
tinte bedruckte papier scheint der
ermöglicht den wert einer banknote
nicht nur aber auch also eher liegt
dieser angebote zugrunde sagt
er ist alleine natürlich noch nicht
hinreichend den wert einer bank ich kann
auch einen papier schon irgendwie
bedrucken daraus wird noch keine
banknoten die einen wert hat ein
objektiv wird da muss noch mehr
dazukommen aber zumindest ist das mal
die basis ohne die eine banknote nicht
auftreten können wir brauchen irgendwie
eine materielle basis ohne die geht es
nicht im sinne der banknote das wäre es
eine bankkarte und jetzt stellt sich die
frage wie ist das verhältnis zu
verstehen von dieser materiellen basis
um diese virtuellen realität die darauf
reagiert
das heißt obwohl virtuelle realitäten
von physischen realität abhängen also
der werde
quote von dem papier sind sie nicht ohne
bedeutungsverlust darauf reduziert der
wert einer banknote der ist nicht
derselbe wie der wert dieses papiers der
wert dieser papiere ist vielleicht zehn
cent 20 cent wenn der aber 1000 euro
drauf steht dann ist das 1000 euro wert
sofern es eben ein offizieller
geldschein ist der eben durch die
europäische zentralbank oder welche
institute sauber und auch immer
autorisiert wurde er nicht gefälscht ist
virtuelle realität verhält sich zur
physischen realität der technik am
beispiel technik wie mentale phänomene
also gedanken stimmungen qualia zur
physischen realität des gehirns wären
meine teams gibt ja also eine
entsprechung wir können unsere
subjektiven zustände wie unsere gedanken
zur meinung nicht ohne bedeutungsverlust
auf irgendwelche büro neuronaler
verschaltungen im gehirn reduzieren
damit erkläre mir nicht wie es ist eine
bestimmte stimmung zu haben also diesen
subjektiven gehalt erklären die nicht
werden wir das phänomen reduzieren auf
die hirnorganische struktur wir können
es natürlich genauer erklären
beschreiben aber den subjektiven gehalt
der mentale phänomene auszeichnen den
begreifen wir dadurch nicht und so
scheint es mir ganz ähnlich auch mit
virtuellen realität im falle digitalität
und der technik zu sein wir können es
genauso wenig ohne bedeutungsverlust auf
reduzieren jetzt kann man noch ein
bisschen weiter vorne jetzt wird's
rechts kompliziert deswegen reise das
nur kurz an das ist jetzt also ein
bisschen etwas das verhältnis von
physischer und virtueller realität lässt
sich jetzt genauer bestimmen in szene
einer konstitution redaktion und dazu
gibt es jetzt einen text von radeberger
dass es eine recht bedeutende
amerikanische philosophin die kürzlich
verstorben ist die hat diese
konstitution relation also das
verhältnis zum beispiel von banknoten
diesem papier und dem wert genau das
stimmt ich zitiere mal auf englisch wird
general idea of confusion ist des
ratings orywal circumstances new things
you kainz of things
jens corssen power is coming to exist
konstitution ist
pieces of paper konstituiert dollar bis
auf klaus konstituiert flex pieces of
moscow news
also sich sagt konstitution ist eine
relation zwischen materiellen dingen und
daraufhin agierenden dingen die überall
uns im alltag bedeutung hat und sie
bringt eben auch das beispiel zwischen
papier stück und dollar
banknote und die papierstücke
konstituieren diese banknoten obwohl sie
nicht damit identisch sind konstitution
bedeutet nicht identität sondern eben
nur die basis auf der app reagieren kann
man könnte jetzt dieses verhältnis noch
viel genauer bestimmen für unsere zwecke
reicht hier meine these ist wir können
das verhältnis zwischen für sie schon
realität und virtueller realität ganz im
sinne dieser konstitution relation zu
stehen weil ja auch dollar noten und
ihre werte virtueller natur sind auf
diese virtuelle realität geht mir gar
nicht ein aber ich finde diese relation
sehr hilfreich um dieses verhältnis
genauer zu bestehen und es zeigt aber
auch konstitution und virtuelle realität
ist nichts ausgefallen ist ist nichts
was irgendeiner neben welt da vor sich
hin geistert sind ist es alltäglich das
ist lebens wirklich völlig normal wir
haben es uns im alltag ständig mit
virtuellen realitäten zu tun und ständig
greifen konstruktions relationen 19
alltag
so das heißt virtuelle realitäten sind
nicht auf eine bestimmte physische
grundlage angewiesen sie sehen durch
ihre unabhängigkeit von physischen
multipel realisierbar damit meine ich
folgendes die virtuelle realität des
geldes kann durch ganz verschiedene
materielle gegenstände konstituiert
werden zum beispiel durch muscheln die
ersten währungen waren auch muscheln in
der urzeit auch durch papier im ziel der
banknoten aber auch durch plastik ist es
möglich denken sie an eine geldkarte mit
einem bestimmten betrag
sie können sich verschiedene andere
materielle grundlage noch denken
wir können die selbe virtuelle realität
nämlich irgendwie ein geld wert durch
verschiedene physische
grundlagen realisieren im sinne dieser
konstitution es kommt nicht darauf an
was dem zugrunde legt es muss aber
irgendwie etwas zu grunde liegen das
heißt ganz unabhängig ist das virtuelle
nie von der physischen realität das ist
immer darauf angewiesen aber eben nicht
so stark darauf beschränkt es ist
multipel realisierbar
ja jetzt habe ich einen erweiterten
rückblick auf die letzte sitzung gegeben
und jetzt möchte ich noch mal kurz auf
das neu eingehen was im zentrum der
heutigen zu lesen steht nämlich um die
raum und zeit lobt der digitalität die
chrono kopie ich möchte jetzt zunächst
mal auf die raum logik auf die räumliche
bedeutung der digitalität eingehen
virtuelle realitäten und das ist es im
schein die die existieren nicht in raum
und zeit
obwohl sie von raum zeitlichen
strukturen konstituiert werden beispiel
online guthaben oder gegenstände
virtuelle gegenstände im internet die
existieren nicht in raum und zeit wie es
physische vorbilder tun also ein apfel
existiert der wirtin raum seite wird von
tag zu tag schlechter wenn man online
guthaben ist es nicht so der wert wird
vielleicht sogar größer vielleicht auch
kleiner hat jetzt einen anderen grund
wegen der zinsen aber prinzipiell bleibt
der konstante ist völlig unabhängig von
der zahl und auch der die räumlichkeit
ist nicht so eindeutig zu bestimmen wie
es beim apfel ist der apfel befindet
sich auf dieser koordinate 44 grad nord
und sophie grad
west oder wie auch immer auf diesen
breiten und längengrade diese
koordinaten das können sie bei online
guthaben bei einem online betrag nicht
zu sagen sie können höchstens sagen
der befindet sich auf dieser bank aber
wenn es ein online guthaben ist dann
stellt sich die frage geht es um die
hauptfiliale dieser bank oder um alle
dependancen oder in dem serverraum
wenn es online ist es ist ja irgendwie
überall ist in dem server drin das geld
ich glaube nicht dass wir so von dem
online geld online wären reden könnte
dass diese währung da in diesem server
drin ist ja wo genau in dem server
dieser festplatte da da ändert sich doch
kein moment alles und doch nur
datensignale da kann ich doch das geld
nicht auffinden also es wird ganz
schwierig zu sagen so jetzt das geld ist
ja mit gegenständen im internet verhält
sich ganz ähnlich alles ist miteinander
vernetzt es ist irgendwie überall oder
auch nirgendwo also wir können einfach
nicht sinnvoll nach dem raum fragen es
wissen kategorien fehler in meinen augen
nach dem ort virtuelle realität zu
fragen
damit hängt zusammen das virtuelle
gegenstände durch eine super
leitfähigkeit und reibungslose zeit
miteinander verbunden sind die sich der
digitalen technik verdankt als im
internet ist alles sofort
erlangen können beträge sofort über weiß
auf andere banken andré kontext bringen
mit nur einem klick das geht reibungslos
sie unterliegen nicht mehr der reibung
wie es zb der fall ist wenn sie jetzt
mit banknoten von einem ort zum anderen
bringt von einer bank auf eine andere
einzahlen dann müssen sie eine physische
raum zeitliche reibung in kauf nehmen
auch wenn sie noch so gering ist sie
brauchen zeit bis sie das ganze
überweisen sie müssen es räumlich
bewegen und diese bewegung findet in
raum und zeit nicht mehr statt von
virtuellen werden vielleicht ein
bisschen zeitlich aber auch da das ist
so schnell nicht von sekundenbruchteilen
dass man eigentlich gar nicht mehr
wirklich von einer zeitlichkeit reden
kann das führt mich jetzt so genauere
beschreibung der zeit der digitalität
mir scheint das virtuelle realitäten
keiner sukzessiven zeit logik folge also
dass sie auch nicht sich in der zeit
verändern sie sind kein
alterungsprozessen ausgesetzt auch kein
wachstumsprozesse dann könnte das jetzt
diskutieren und dann des geldes durch
die zins vermehrung aber ich glaube dass
dies nicht typische virtuelle realitäten
ist das ist eben typisch das geld es
gibt nur die realität wo das nicht der
fall ist die sie geben konstant bleiben
das heißt virtuelle realitäten sind
zeitlich überall präsent ubiquitär
überall und immer gegenwärtig sind
überall gegen werden an jedem ort gegen
fertig das könnte man auch die ubi
präsenz sehen also op heißt wo
kubikfuß als überall und präsenz eben
gibt gegenwart ich glaube dass wir so
über die zeit der virtuellen realität
sprechen müssen ich schon sagte die
ordnung der virtuellen realität ist
nicht so sehr sukzessiv zeitlich zu
verstehen wie es bei physisch gebundenen
realitäten der fall ist zudem sind diese
vernetzung das können sich sehr gut
anhang des internets ziehen wo auch
alles miteinander in beziehung steht und
dieses früher oder später diese relation
keine große bedeutung mehr hält es geht
im internet eher darum was hält mit mir
zusammen im sinne der beziehungen sind
ja auch das aspekt unter dem wir etwas
betrachten aber die zeit logik wann
diese informationen gewannen diese
gegenstand entstand der spielt immer
weniger eine rolle eben weil aber das
miteinander in beziehung steht dieses
alles wenn man in beziehung setzen des
internets bedient so würde ich
argumentieren eine neue zeit logik und
jetzt können wir diesem jahr neue zeit
logik nämlich diese zeitlose zeit wie
man es auch nennen könnte der virtuellen
realität der digitalität mit der
zeitlosen c reihe von john mit tackert
in verbindung bringen von max eckart ist
ein philosoph des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts der sehr sehr zentral
zwischen drei reihen derzeit
verschiedene hat eine partei einer bier
ein erzähler ich komme gleich noch genau
dort zu sprechen und die c reihe
schalten hier besonders entschieden zu
sein weil sie eine zeitlose zeit
bedeutet die zeit der digitalität ist
keine chronologische zeit die sukzession
ausgesetzt ist oder sukzession bedingt
sondern eine logische zeit die also im
sinne der kleinen netz und zu denen ist
der bezüge nicht so sehr dass früher
oder später bis jetzt zukünftigen oder
vergangen sondern das meer stehen im
sinn eine sekte ssten sinne von
bedeutung die der beziehung in der eben
etwas steht als die beziehung wird im
virtuellen raum nicht mehr so sehr
zeitlich zu denken sein sondern ihr
logisch jetzt möchte ich noch kurz diese
drei zeitreihen von mittäters vorstellen
also es gibt eine art hatte ich gesagt
die arbeit die wo es in die index ik
lische bezugsrahmen gibt als zb ein
jetzt ich habe deswegen hier von drei
zuständen derzeit gesprochen die in der
alphabetischen reihenfolge der
sukzession hier beschrieben sind
mmmm alphabet l m n o ist es eine
sukzession l m n o p q r s t u und so
weiter das heißt hier gibt es eine
abfolge einem logik der abfolge die aber
jetzt nach der arai so bestimmt werden
kann das wie eines dieser momente als
ein jetzt identifizieren könnten decsi
kalisch als mit dem hinweisen und dann
davon dass noch
ausstehende ereignis das und das bereits
vergangene ereignisse als nicht mehr
real klassifizieren können das m ist
nicht mehr ein jetzt ist vergangen
durchgelaufen sie können sich das nie
ein durchlaufen wie so ein zeitstrahl
uns durchläuft gezeigt verfliest es die
fließende zeit und das oh das ist noch
nicht real das kommt erst noch auf uns
zu vivendi zukunft auf und durchfließt
also praktisch die andere richtung mit
der zeit weil hier gibt es also von
rechts nach links wir sind hier durch
uns durchläuft das heißt sm ist schon
durch diesen jetzt durchgelaufen nach
links und das kommt noch durch und durch
das ist die arbeit subjektive index
italien zeit jetzt
zukünftig und vergangen erlaubt zu
klassifizieren
davon unterscheidet mit tegra 3
sie sehen jetzt hier hier gibt es jetzt
nichts gestrichelt es mehr gibt es auch
kein jetzt teil der einen bestimmten
punkt in der zeit als jetzt ausweist
aber sie haben immer noch den zeit fällt
das heißt die zeit
hat eine richtung eines sukzession die
b3 wird aber häufig die präsent ist
ische zeitreihe genannt weil hier die
zeit so zu verstehen uns dass uns alle
zeit punkte vor augen liegen also wir
überblicken die gesamte zeit die zeit
läuft nicht mehr durch uns durch will
sich nicht mehr subjekt der zeit sondern
es ein starker optimistisches
zeitverständnis präsentismus oder eterna
liz muss nennt man das häufig wir sind
alle zeit zuständig zum stimme präsent
allerdings sind sie insofern voneinander
unterschieden als immer noch gesagt wird
zustand m ist vor zustand n und zustand
ist vor zustand auch wenn zustand mm
nach zustand im erfolgte weil hier eben
noch die richtung der zeit die
sukzessive zeit nach der bereits
vorhanden ist und jetzt unterscheidet
mittäter eben noch eine zeit da müssen
sie jetzt genau hinschauen was jetzt im
gegensatz zur bereit sie haben es
wahrscheinlich gesehen es fehlt hier
dieser zeit fallen die c3 hat keine
wirkliche sukzession mehr sony c3 ist
nur noch eine logische relation von
verschiedenen zuständen die nicht mehr
dahingehend priorisiert sind dass sie
aufeinander zeitlich folgen es gibt hier
vielleicht eine zeitliche eine folge
aber die folge ist nicht mehr zeitlich
zu verstehen sondern logisch
aber eben nicht dass diese folge jetzt
so zu verstehen ist dass
nach em- oder uhr nach dem auftritt
sondern sie stehen in einer anderen
zeitung ich glaube eben dass wir die
sukzession 2 ist wenn man so sprechen
kann von virtuellen realitäten im sinne
dieser zustimmen kann er spielt die
sukzession keine rolle mehr inszeniert
derzeit spielt auch die in lexika lied
ist jetzt dass früher oder später nicht
mehr zeit hier haben wir alle
informationen zum beispiel vor uns
liegen hier spielen die information
bezüglich der zeitlichkeit nicht mehr so
sind die rolle hier zu spielen andere
relationen eine rolle ihres mit der
logik der bedeutung der nähe oder ferne
von anderen informationen weil eben
alles miteinander vernetzt ist ja das
war eine kurze noch vorläufiger am
ausblick auf die
zeit und raum
verständnis der digitalität ich gehe
dann im nächsten sitzung nochmals
genauer ein möchte jetzt auch schon ein
vorausblick geben auf die nächste
sitzung in der wir dann endlich
übergehen auf die ethik der digitalität
nachdem wir viel vorarbeit geleistet
haben wie ich schon sagte wir müssen
erst verstehen wie die ontologie der
digitalität zu fassen ist bevor wir uns
wirklich mit ethischen fragen
auseinandersetzen können solange wir
nicht bestimmt haben die virtuelle
realität zu verstehen ist können wir
nicht von ethischen problemstellungen
reden weil uns die ganze basis fehlt die
beurteilungs basis bedienen also über
auf die ewige digitalität und hier auf
das internet hat sich schon oft
gesprächen gekommen bin das internet als
einen handlungsraum und nicht nur als
ein mädchen wir werden uns überlegen wie
wir im internet
handeln wie wir nicht nur in von
internet informationen und beschaffen
das hatte ich im bereich der vorletzten
sitzung behandelt da mache ich auch mal
oben rechts in den kleinen wo ist die
psychologie des netz gehen die in der
nächsten sitzung geht nicht darum wie
wir wissen oder orientieren internet für
uns verschaffen die wir versuchen
sondern wie der etwas tun und das halte
ich für die eigentlich spannende frage
weil wir ja gerade hier auch etwas tun
in denen wir hier miteinander
korrespondieren im virtuellen raum der
digitalität das wird also das thema sein
das wird ein spannendes thema sein und
ich bedanke mich für die aufmerksamkeit
und wünsche ihnen noch eine schöne woche